[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Anna or
Anna is with us in Los Angeles Hi how
are you hello um how are you I'm doing
great good how can we
help um so I've been working for some
time now and um I I thought I I did a
okay job for Building up my personal
wealth but um I also like um to hear uh
your opinion about how I'm doing this
far okay how are you doing tell me about
it yeah so um I've been in the real
estate business um for many years um
personally I have four rental properties
and the yearly income is about 50,000
given or more or less um the total
Mortgage Balance I have about is a a
million
um and one thing um I don't know what
what I was thinking but I did take out a
home equity line um the purpose of uh
purchasing other properties um so so far
I've been paying it off the highest it
was close to
600,000 but based on my calculation
that's back in 2019 and I should be able
to pay that off completely off um by
next year um middle of next year then
you'll still have then you'll still have
a million dollars out on the rentals
correct yes okay and you make what a
year uh that's the wild card so I'm in
real estate so that's you make last year
hard to say last year is about 200 okay
all right that's probably your average
year right yes yeah all right good for
you and so what's your plan just stay in
Deb the rest of your life I mean what's
your
plan so sounds like it because it sounds
like you keep buying rentals with more
debt yeah and and that's my question
although I have these rental properties
but I I I always
feel I have this piece of rock um in
inside of me it's I feel that very heavy
yep so it's a million dollar
Rock it's right there in your stomach
yeah yeah so should I get rid of some of
the properties so to get rid of this
feeling um I'm not sure what to do I
would develop a game plan to have them
all paid off within a certain period of
time there's nothing panicked here
because there's no desperate situation
but what you're experiencing is you
finally are measuring
risk and most of us I grew up in the
real estate business H so I you know I
understand when you get in the real
estate business one of the things they
do is they take a hammer and they break
your risk
meter we don't even know how to measure
risk once we're in that business cuz we
just buy crap I mean it's just like we
go get get a getting a mortgage to buy
an investment property is like that's
the only way to do it in our minds you
can't do it you can't do it otherwise
we've just people in the real estate
business really believe that it's just
not true but we believe it to be true so
um but what you're you're starting to
feel the weight of the risk that you've
taken on that no one in your world talks
about but you're starting to feel it and
that's what how you ended up talking to
us so yeah what are these properties
worth total you owe a million on them
what are they worth total total total I
would say about 5 million good for you
okay so that's a great Equity position I
mean obviously you're in a 20% loan to
value ratio which is phenomenal that
that's not a big risk position but there
is a million dollar worth of problems
there so what I would do is say I'm
going to pay off that million with my
income and with the sale strategically
of one or a couple of these properties
over the next five
years okay and it might be you can just
sell one of them and be clear and clear
the rest of them and that'd be pretty
cool and then from there you pay cash
for all of your additions to your
portfolio you don't use home equity
loans ever again you don't borrow again
to do that because you've got great cash
flow when you have no mortgages and that
that's going to be the way to go yeah
she's going to be in a really great
position out there so now I'm curious
Dave so you wouldn't sell why not sell
one of the houses and knock it out that
way yeah that's what I'm saying I'd pick
out one of those properties got all
right all right and and or the income
but I mean if it takes you two years to
do this in instead of a month right
that's okay okay there's nothing on fire
but you do want to aim at having a debt
free portfolio and aim at and stick with
the promise to yourself that any
additions to the portfolio we're doing
with cash yeah as soon as we get first
and foremost get to debt free then when
we add something later we're going to do
that with uh you know without borrowing
money to do that and folks I understand
that the get-rich quick real estate
world and borrow all you can on real
estate out there is out there it's
always been out there and I understand
it's real hot again that Tic Tac has
made it really a big thing again and uh
you guys get on there and there's all
these goobers on there that have no life
history that you know they're 14 years
old and they're I'm buying houses and I
got these figure
it's a bunch of crap you don't I
mean when I was 22 years old out of
college I started buying houses nothing
down I bought $4 million worth I had a
$1 million net worth by the time I was
24 years old I made
$250,000 cash taxable income doing flips
in
1984 that's $20,000 a month in 1984
before you want put that in today's
dollars that's a half million dollars a
year okay now I don't know what
neighborhood you grew up in but the
neighborhood I grew up in we called that
rich it was fun I was having a blast
until I found out about risk and the
banks called our notes and we spent the
next two and a half years of our life
losing everything we owned we were sued
we were foreclosed on and with a brand
new baby a toddler and a marriage
Hanging On by a thread cuz my poor wife
thought she had Mar married sir Galahad
turns out it was
goober and there we were bankrupt and at
28 years old I got the opportunity to
start completely over because I followed
the exact same crap you people are
seeing on Instagram and Tik Tok and
you're all walking around acting like
you're smart you're not you're straight
up freaking stupid quit doing it I
walked it and don't tell me you know
more listen a man with an experience is
not at the mercy of a man with an
opinion this is ridiculous you guys I've
walked the exact path that some of you
are signing up for right now now not her
she's got a different situation she's
moving away from the debt she's calling
about that but this zero down nothing
down I'm going to get rich in real
estate is absolute bull crap broke
people shouldn't buy real estate it
makes them broker that's why they call
them Brokers this is the show